اخبار الحرب على غزه بايجاز من الضفه
الغربيه اهلا بكم قصف الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يتواصل في انحاء متفرقه من قطاع غزه شهداء
وجرحى في قصف لمبنى سكني في رفح واستشهاد
طفل خلال استهداف قوات الاحتلال مدخل
مدرسه تؤوي نازحين في جبالي البلد ووزاره
الصحه في غزه تقول ان الاحتلال ارتكب ع
مجازر راح ضحيتها
128 شهيدا
واكثر من 160 اصابه خلال يوم جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يعلن اصابه 25 جنديا في معارك
غزه خلال 24 ساعه اشتباكات عنيفه بين
المقاومه وقوات الاحتلال في خان يونس
جنوبي غزه ومخيم المغازي وسط القطاع كتائب
القسام تقول انها اجهزت على عشره جنود من
مسافه صفر في محيط مخيم البريج
اسماعيل هنيه يصف اغتيال نائب رئيس حركه
حماس في غزه صالح العاروري بالعمل
الارهابي ويقول انه انتهاك لسياده لبنان
رئيس الموساد يقول ان كل من شارك في هجوم
السابع من اكتوبر دمه مهدور ومسؤولون
امريكيون يقولون ان العمليه ضمن هجمات
سريه تنفذها اسرائيل ضد حماس وايران تقول
ان الاغتيال عمل ارهابي تشدد على ان
اسرائيل اخلت بتوازن
المنطقه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقتحم مخيم نور
شمس في طول كرم ويعتقل عددا من
الفلسطينيين معصوبي الاعين ويعلن المخيم
منطقه عسكريه مغلقه ويفرض حضر التجوال فيه
وقوات الاحتلال تشن حمله اقتحامات
ومداهمات في عدد من المدن والبلدات
الفلسطينيه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
n